[Aplausos]
[Música]
porque unos países son ricos y otros
países son pobres puede parecer una
pregunta fácil pero nada más lejos de la
realidad de hecho el origen de la
riqueza es una de las cuestiones clave
sino la más importante en el debate
político
whitman 9 en abril cuando presentó cafés
[Música]
wii hay países pobres porque hay países
ricos tienen los países más ricos alguna
característica geográfica especial que
determine su éxito sobre los recursos
naturales la fuente de su riqueza tal
vez son sus habitantes más inteligentes
o la más importante de todas está la
riqueza dada es decir hay un nivel de
riqueza determinado que simplemente
tenemos que distribuir
[Música]
la más vulnerable
si amigos y la respuesta a todas estas
preguntas fuera que si entonces
podríamos decir que nuestra suerte está
dada no la podríamos cambiar si somos
ricos estupendo y si somos pobres
aparentemente sólo tendríamos dos
caminos o resignarnos o confiar en algún
líder mesiánico que nos prometa alguna
revolución claro que casi siempre estas
revoluciones terminan peor nosotros no
queremos ser rico ser rico es malo en
inhumano
sin embargo esperando un momento porque
creo que en este planteamiento falla
alguna que otra cosa bueno sinceramente
creo que fallan muchas cosas
evidentemente amigos son muchos los
factores que hacen que un país sea rico
o sea pobre en este vídeo nos vamos a
centrar en uno de los factores en una de
las cuestiones más importantes y lo
vamos a hacer echando un vistazo a la
historia de américa atentos
[Música]
américa versus américa
américa un mismo continente con dos
realidades muy pero que muy diferentes
unos países son muy ricos y otros países
muy pobres fijaos por ejemplo la renta
per cápita de canadá incluso teniendo en
cuenta la diferencia de precios es cinco
veces la del salvador o la de ecuador
por su parte la renta per cápita de eeuu
es casi cuatro veces la de colombia sí
es verdad también en un grupo de países
que podríamos calificar en términos
relativos como de clase media sin ir más
lejos la renta de chile o panamá es tres
veces la de bolivia o casi dos veces la
de perú
sin embargo a grandes rasgos podemos
decir que de las mil millones de
personas que viven en el continente
americano aproximadamente el 40% viven
en algunos de los países más ricos del
mundo fundamentalmente eeuu y canadá
mientras tanto el otro 60% de los
americanos viven en países que o bien
son muy pobres o que aún están en vías
de desarrollo
[Música]
y claro ante este panorama la pregunta
es por qué diantres existe este
contraste entre las dos grandes
potencias norteamericanas y el resto del
continente o incluso porque los países
que se sitúan en los dos extremos del
continente son en general más ricos
fijaos por ejemplo en este mapa los
países pintados con un color más oscuro
son países más ricos
[Música]
sin embargo tal vez donde más fácil
resulte observar este enorme contraste
es precisamente en esta frontera que
estáis viendo la frontera favorita de
donald trump la frontera entre eeuu y
méxico en el lado norte de la frontera
eeuu uno de los países más ricos del
mundo un país donde con carácter general
sus habitantes son bastante más ricos y
viven más seguros y más años que sus
vecinos del lado sur de la frontera es
decir de méxico de hecho es cruzar la
frontera y de repente todo cambia pero
porque semejante diferencia a que se
debe al fin y al cabo hablamos ojo de
territorios con una población y unos
recursos naturales muy similares no
olvidemos que gran parte de california
texas y nuevo méxico algunos de los
estados por cierto más prósperos e
innovadores de los eeuu eran a comienzos
del siglo 19 territorio de mexico
y además como ya hemos visto aquí en
visual político la gente que logra
trasladarse del sur de la frontera al
norte tiene unas tasas de empleo y
emprendimiento bastante altas así que
desde luego no estamos hablando de un
motivo racial religioso o de recursos
pero entonces repito la pregunta por qué
diantres existe este enorme contraste
entre el lado norte de la frontera y el
lado sur sí vale seguro que muchos de
vosotros estáis pensando obvio porque
han tenido gobiernos y políticos peores
pero cuál es el origen acaso casi todos
los países que se encuentran al sur de
la frontera entre eeuu y méxico han
tenido tan mala suerte no habrá caso
algo más pues atentos
[Música]
destinos diferentes
amigos para continuar tenemos que hacer
un pequeño viaje tenemos que
trasladarnos ni más ni menos que hasta
el año 1600 imaginemos dos hermanos juan
y pedro que están a punto de emprender
la aventura americana desde algún puerto
de la vieja europa pero por cuestiones
del destino lo van a hacer en barcos
diferentes
[Música]
veréis uno de los hermanos juan partió
en busca de fortuna hacia méxico
mientras que pedro se subió a un barco
que se dirigía más al norte a lo que más
tarde se conoció como nueva inglaterra y
que hoy corresponde a los estados de new
hampshire connecticut massachusetts
vermont maine y rhode island
si hoy una de las zonas más ricas de los
eeuu ahora bien la pregunta es si
vosotros tuvierais estado en el lugar de
estos dos hermanos que barco hubierais
preferido el que se dirigía méxico o el
que se dirigía a nueva inglaterra a
boston pues amigos para los que hayáis
respondido que boston
creo que os conviene darle una vuelta a
vuestra decisión porque en aquel momento
las cosas no podían ser más diferentes
veréis juan llegó a méxico capital una
ciudad repleta de monumentos y nuevas
edificaciones una ciudad que no tenía
nada que envidiar a las ciudades
europeas
en aquel momento méxico formaba parte
del virreinato de nuevo a españa una
área de gobernación gigantesca que
estaba repleta de maravillas campos
cultivados ruinas de antiguas
civilizaciones grandes ciudades etcétera
etcétera por su parte pedro llegó un
territorio frío desolado despoblado un
lugar sin infraestructuras y donde la
mera supervivencia era un reto difícil
un lugar donde el hambre y el frío
hacían estragos
precisamente los conquistadores
españoles no avanzaron más entre otras
cosas porque más al norte no había
ninguna riqueza que extraer los ingleses
no eligieron norteamérica porque fuera
una zona atractiva sino porque era lo
único que estaba disponible los
territorios deseables de américa con
abundancia de población indígena y minas
de oro y plata que explotar ya habían
sido ocupados de arona se movió y james
robinson porque fracasan los países en
nueva inglaterra amigos para tratar
siquiera de sobrevivir había que
trabajar muy duro
en el sur en cambio las cosas eran muy
diferentes
había muchísimas riquezas naturales el
clima era mucho mejor para la
agricultura y había muchísima población
local que fue utilizada por los
conquistadores españoles para que
realizaran interminables horas de
trabajo a cambio de prácticamente nada
el caso es que todos estos recursos
permitieron que muchos de los que
llegaron no tuvieran que trabajar para
sobrevivir y no sólo eso además se pudo
replicar fácilmente muchas de las
instituciones que había en la vieja
europa instituciones como la
aristocracia la burocracia es decir los
funcionarios o las gracias reales que
eran privilegios otorgados por el estado
en beneficio de unos pocos monopolios
comerciales reparto de tierras
explotaciones mineras etcétera etcétera
de esta forma poco a poco por un lado se
fue forjando una cultura que percibía
que el trabajo y el emprendimiento no
eran la mejor forma de prosperar sino
saber relacionarse bien con quienes
tenían el poder para que arriesgarse
emprender si es mejor poner la mano por
otro lado se consolidó una élite formada
por personas que vivían gracias a los
recursos que extraían de todos los demás
mediante privilegios mediante la
explotación por la fuerza de los nativos
mediante la entrega de tierras
concesiones rentas públicas impuestos
etcétera etcétera
una elite que por cierto para los
cánones de la época vivía a todo trapo
con todo tipo de comodidades lo que
suponía tener que extraer más y más
recursos de los demás es decir esta
élite que controlaba los recursos
económicos no sólo no se preocupaba de
emprender innovar arriesgarse sino que
encima ponían trabas al resto
y amigos desgraciadamente esta cultura
no desapareció con la independencia sino
que en gran medida se mantuvo y cimentó
algunas de las características más
notables de hispanoamérica una élite con
mucha riqueza basada en la obtención de
rentas caciques mucha burocracia y un
ascensor social destrozado mientras
tanto en el norte las cosas discurrirán
por un camino completamente distinto
[Música]
la supervivencia
a diferencia de lo que ocurría en el sur
en el norte no había recursos ni
población indígena a la que explotar así
que no quedaba otra que trabajar duro
emprender e innovar para mejorar el
nivel de vida
así la cultura social que se fue
gestando las instituciones que se
desarrollaron eran muy diferentes el
trabajo físico el trabajo duro por
ejemplo estaba bien visto y no sólo eso
como además estos territorios eran muy
pobres y estaban prácticamente
despoblados gozaron de muchísima
autonomía política y económica digamos
que al principio la corona británica no
le importaban mucho estas colonias
estaba más preocupada de lo que ocurría
en otros lugares de su imperio que eran
mucho más lucrativos de hecho cuando
estas colonias se empezaron a prosperar
es precisamente cuando la corona puso su
atención sobre ellas lo que significa
que la corona empezó a establecer
controles políticos controles económicos
y más impuestos y amigos los colonos no
estaban por la labor
se suele decir que la guerra de
independencia de los eeuu fue una lucha
por obtener la libertad sin embargo
muchos de los incentivos que les
llevaron a luchar tenían que ver
precisamente con mantener una libertad
que ya tenían y a la que ya no estaban
dispuestos a renunciar
[Música]
de ahí que una vez obtenida la
independencia se preocupara mucho de que
ni sus libertades ni sus capacidades
para emprender correrán riesgos pero
puede que alguno de vosotros esté
pensando enrique un momento te olvidas
de la esclavitud pues amigos es que
precisamente los estados esclavistas no
eran ni con mucho los más ricos la
esclavitud enriquece a unos pocos a
costa del resto desde luego sí en vez de
dos hermanos hubiéramos hablado de dos
empresas a largo plazo hubiera sido
mucho pero que mucho mejor invertir en
la de boston y es que las claves del
desarrollo no están en los recursos
naturales ni en la explotación de nadie
sino en el ingenio en el espíritu
emprendedor y en el trabajo por eso
cuando los políticos dificultan este
proceso por ejemplo con muchos impuestos
un estado enorme mucha burocracia o
privilegios a los amiguetes los
resultados siempre siempre son malos muy
malos en cierto modo es algo similar a
lo que pasa con los recursos naturales
pueden ayudar pero no bastan para
generar riqueza hay países muy ricos sin
apenas recursos naturales como japón o
singapur y otros con muchos recursos
pero muy pobres como venezuela el
ingenio el trabajo y el capital son más
importantes que cualquier recurso
natural
la buena noticia amigos es que la
pobreza no es algo determinado se puede
escapar de ella desde luego trayectorias
como la que han mantenido países como
chile o panamá en las últimas décadas
demuestran que las cosas pueden cambiar
pero ahora turno para ti
crees que veremos próximamente el
despegue de américa latina'
déjanos tu respuesta en los comentarios
y también en esta encuesta y como
siempre si te ha resultado interesante
el vídeo echarnos una mano dándole a
like y suscribiéndote a visual político
si aún no lo has hecho un saludo y hasta
la próxima
[Música]
[Aplausos]